друзі витаючи всіх нас на ринок вже 20 00
це означає людина завдання дня спочатку
провини в ефірі платформа та масивного піт
ринку міністерства святі та наука україни
і я і мудрий відірвав думі страшенно ми
продовжуємо говорити про на t маяки та
актуальному сьогодні за раз для кожного
українця тому, що в нашій вкрай вина
і ми точно датовані від і волосся та
сам цьому сьогодні ми закидаємо
Дена століття точно знаю багатий вид поводження
на наші за харчування з приводу ванна
пасивним психологом і сьогодні ми будемо
раді знаю на тему я кас тусується травми
провини липні я вітаю вас привіт
здрасте володимир здравствуйте дорогі
друзі
абсолютно вірно владимир неможливо
підготуватися до війни навіть якщо знати про
ній тому абсолютно актуальна тема
психічна травма війни і чекаю на ваші
питання ну давайте туди нудного на
прогноз таке за вільну рамку вже
більше місяця з відривом і
з місяць але там же 5 ти ж не в
повних нас супроводжують такі крім
ціни вироби вид стану шок навчаються
підірвали таки вибивається правіше
навантажуєте на тягу нам здавалося що
таке винам уже будуть і мало хто у нас
правда циферів за гострими локальними вже
ніби заповніть на винака фільмах про
другу світловому точно не цей ціну з
друк шок путін путін якось nadia
шляхом розривання путін psy кадр з
маріуполя з харкова з їх міс чорнила
і так далі тут осягнуто плюс мінус
100 плюс 100 мінус влади пройшло вже
п'ять ти живий чим можна сказати ще такі
музейний стан вин я нехай ну негативного
виду кидається на психіці любити кохані
на ну цинічно здоров'я
на сьогоднішній день ми держава на
яку напали ми держави в
стан війни підлою несподіваною в
будь-якому разі несподіваної тому
адаптуватися що у 21 столітті коли є
космічний туризм штучний
інтелект уявити, що мирні міста
будуть бомбити неможливо абсолютно я б
сказала адекватна реакція
українцева україни зараз йдеться
насамперед про емоційну
когнітивної фізичної біологічної
енергетична реакція на цю ситуацію
адекватно
важкої травми, бо психічна
травма війни є ще бойова психічна
травма війни та її переживає наші
захисники які безпосередньо
беруть участь у бойових діях але ми сьогодні
будемо говорити про мирних людей, які
всіляко допомагають нашим захисникам але
проте знаходиться не на передовій
але не точно переживає найважчий
вранці вона так і називається психічна
травма війни це взагалі то є
терміном цю травму вивчає але вона все
ще досі залишається недостатньо
вивченою і тим не менш певні
напрацювання є і так що можна сказати
з приводу цієї травми те, що ви описали
якусь синусоїду це абсолютно я б
сказала адекватна реакція психіки на
такі тяжкий стан
і кінець стані впоратися причому поза
залежно від того чи це сильно
чи стійкі це чоловік чи це слабка
чутлива дівчина жінка чи це
дитина тому що всі потрапляють у цю
ситуацію немає такої психіка, яка могла
б адаптуватися до стресу
загрози смерті будь-якої миті загрози
смерті власної або смерті близькі за
тяжкості
впливу подібні травми на психіку
іноді порівнюють
деякі руйнівні
масштабні природне явище тобто
природні катаклізми і це
приблизно однакові землетруси
і виверження вулкана тобто абсолютно
несподіване коли людина не може
контролювати ситуацію тобто страх
розпач волі неможливість
контролювати це дуже близькі і ось у
цих двох випадках форс-мажорів
відчуття емоційний прояв але все
ж травма війни вважається сильнішою тому
що це ще й колосальна
несправедливість та абсолютна
несподіванка особливо 21 столітті
відразу треба сказати що
умовно тому, що є дуже багато
всяких поділів
психологічних типів людей
залежно від типу нервової системи
тому що у кожного з нас по-перше
різна нервова система за її стилем за її
рухливості з її врівноваженості нехай
ми такими народжуються але ще й у тих
умовах яких кожен із нас зайшов у
ситуацію ж у нас були різні
умова різні здоров'я але тим не менш
тому що яскраво психотерапевт змушена
відзначати всі індивідуальні особливості
входження людини в цю травму але потрібно
сказати що переважно люди діляться
на 2 типи
психологічно психологічно
сприйняття
відчуття цієї травми це прямо ось
24 лютого вночі телефонний дзвінок або
інформація про те, що наша банда і у
людини миттєво настає
колосальне неврастенії нервове
виснаження це коли людина раптом за
одну хвилину втрачає всі сили всі ресурси
які взагалі можна
якими він міг потім шукати
скористатися для того, щоб жити
вижити психологічно підтримувати себе
потрібно, щоб люди розуміли що
взагалі-то
природна реакція центральної нервової
системи нашої психі а подібну ситуацію
тобто таке може
бути це втома це нервова втома
це фізична втома це ми всі
бачимо або подібні люди бачать все в
вкрай негативному світлі вони якимось
особливим знаєте почуттям знаходять саму
негативну інформацію, тобто ця
колосальна песимізму втома є
другий тип людей, які реагують деяким
і стероїдним таким компонентам тобто
люди які агресують у яких
колосальна рухова активність
яка пишуть мені наказано кажуть у мене
така ненависть такий гнів це майже не
нормально я хочу одразу сказати це
нормально ж психіка реагує
або аутоагресії людина починає
вбивати сам себе, бо не може
впоратися з ситуацією чи все-таки
агресія виходить назовні ось це основні
дві основні дві реакції на подібну
ситуацію
Юлія трахкав точно не а то можна любина
переходить і зубного стало менше години
зум його на так що ти ну ось туди я буду
бити мощі безумовно і в основному це
таки буває тобто людина як більше
менше починає навіть у стані
неврастенні емоційного виснаження
починати намагатися себе якось
відновити і його хитаїв абсолютно
інший бік бік агресії
ненависті за що
хто винен нам відомо, а ось це
за що агресія
навіть рухова активність тобто
якісь дії іноді дуже хаотично
тому що мозок все-таки в цей момент
дуже погано концентрується і людина з
одного стану потрапляє до іншого та
трапляється коло тому що після ось
цієї агресії та ненависті загалом
часто в дуже широкому розумінні не
конкретному коли можна зібратися і
зробити щось саме передусім
для себе і поберегти а в такому широкому то
є енергія буде нікуди у фізиці під
на стан називається ентропії
незворотній а енергія тобто воно просто
розплющується що треба сказати що
таких станах психологи добре
знає в жодному разі не можна намагатися
людину змусити взяти себе в руки це
неможливо травма війни це страх смерті
і
похідна від страху смерті це
власне страх за а вірніше від
інстинкту самозбереження як смерті це
агресія і цей біль і з цим нікуди не
дінешся до я б сказала сильні
емоції почуття людські тому
вмовляти людину просити її взяти
себе в руки в той момент коли він з
буквально на піку коли він поки що не
може взяти себе в руки з таким
людиною треба розмовляти
таку людину не можна переконати
зупинитися в якийсь момент не можна
застосовувати до нього ніякі фізичні
скажімо методи впливу чи спроби на
Його гостей все до потрібно заспокоїти
заспокоїти в якийсь момент коли
більш-менш він буде в змозі нікого
баланс тому що психіка довго не
витримує такий стан і ось коли
можна пробитися можна з ним
розмовляти
значить, що ще треба сказати я вже
говорила спочатку що є люди які
зазнають колосального виснаження і є
відео які зазнають агресії ось ті
які зазнають агресії яка
кричать яка плаче ці люди
психологічно
відновлюються швидше тому що ті
які виснажуються правило люди з тонкою
нервовою системою з особливими властивостями
нервової системи це ті люди, які
зараз відчуватимуть колосальний
комплекс провини та сорому
причому нізащо таких людей можна
назвати знаєте без вини винні
перебувають вони в Києві чи вони
знаходяться в якихось інших місцях допомог
волонтерів для чи не допомагають вони або в
на даний момент вони просто не в змозі
стати приховувати ним треба підтримати як
говориться саме себе
колосальне почуття провини та сорому буде
бути у таких людей просто по
факт їхньої натури тому що ці люди
завжди об'єднують собі три головні
складова цивілізованої людини
високий інтелект
совість на сцені закон та емоційне
чуйність і вони щоб не відбувалося
у світі вони почуватимуться
колосальний
тут я хочу точно це я зіткнувся на
сюди у нас з вами якраз служити
збірник сік українки вінка ж шоу java
сверблю і хлопцями який відключити а при
вирощуванні рубля дні дістати але для
щоб початки просієте борошно 24 на 7
там ризикує жити all lives він поважає
можна було б ікра щоб дати про авіаносця
правильного так кричу стану
навіть не синдром видих, що вижив це про
другом ми всі залучені до ситуації коли
кожен розуміє свою відповідальність за
то щоб світ настав швидше ось ця
солідарність вона до речі унікальна тим
що вона з одного боку це
єдина складова яка
бореться зі страхом зі страхом можна
поборотися тільки якщо відчуваєш плече
людину, яка поділяє твої
переконання
твої думки твої почуття тоді немає страху
бо ти борешся за себе і за того
хлопця ти воюєш за себе за того хлопця ти
волонтер лише з іншого боку ось
це постійне відчуття недостатності
саме говорить про те, що я багато
що почуття провини є що недостатньо я
роблю що потрібно швидше що потрібно швидше
це до речі говорить про те, наскільки
чутлива наша нація наскільки
українці дивовижний народ це знати
навіть дивує мене та моїх колег якось
в епоху споживання виникало відчуття
що кожен сам по собі і загалом 1 три
нації також які від багатьох європейських
ну нічого нового чекати не доводиться і
тут раптом таке колосальне єднання і
таке почуття допомогти не тільки собі а
насамперед іншому і потім собі
тому тут, безумовно, дуже на це
ніяк не вплинуть з боку людина сама
завдяки власному здоровому глузду
повинен визначити два моменти я завжди
це навіть я точно так само як і все
відчувають почуття провини і сором тому
що недостатньо навіть якщо працювати 12
годин на добу 15 висотки але проте
ось там де вмикаєшся там завжди і то
їсти не потрібно дуже чітко визначити
зону можливого і неможливого тобто я
роблю те, що я можу робити але природа
створила нас вразливими і потребуючим
відпочинку і без цього ми нічого не зможемо
зробити навіть є ми відключимо
зараз нашого психічного життя нашого
колосальна емпатія по відношенню до
іншим ми ще підключимо і ось цей
комплекс провини та сорому ми просто не
зможемо далі функціонувати ми не
зможемо допомогти ні собі ні іншим із цим
потрібно впоратися в контексті здорового
сенсу а робити це можна виключно
ну скажемо так правильними вчинками
яка наводить правильним результатом
розпланувати на сьогодні, тому що ми
ось таких ситуаціях за таких
обставинах
гребуть тій травмі, яку ми проживаємо і
яку нам потрібно прожити ми маємо
пройти просто необхідно для того, щоб
вона не зруйнуй у нас ми повинні пройти
через неї
відчути прямо
ціанування думати ви знаєте як
черчіль це фраза мені дуже запам'яталася
дві фрази 1 черчілля що якщо йдеш
через app продовжуйте не зупиняючись
ось тому я ще на початку хотіла
сказати що якщо реакція людини на
психічну травму вільний шок
людина просто перебувати в комусь
заціпеніння він начебто як і немає в нього
особливих почуттів і немає особливих емоцій, але у
його шок ось такі люди в першу чергу
потребують допомоги
так от і тих через і тип перемозі то з
одного боку йти кожен маленький крок
це мистецтво маленьких кроків кожен
день і друге це те, що на війні все
кошти хороші а ось в даному випадку я
одразу перейду щоб ми з вами все встигли
до того ж а що ж робити тобто до яких
можна все-таки
якщо не перемогти хтось хоча б купірувати
полегшити власну частину та долю
свого близького перше треба розуміти
ще колись consiglio сказав про стадо
реакція на стрес від рама війни звичайно
це не просто стрес та дистрес перше
це агресія те, що ми вже з вами
владимир обговорили вона може піти або в
овні
зовні або назовні і тобто люди можуть
реагувати по 1 агресія є але не всі
можуть її правильно
використовувати друге це адаптація знову
ж адаптаційні механізми у кожного
людини різна і залежить від усього від
особливостей людини від того, як вона ці
механізми та в контексті яких ситуацій
використовують я зараз коротко розповім і
третє це виснаження ось це треба знати
тому для того щоб
вижити жити як процес нам допомагати
собі та іншим зберегти своє
психологічне здоров'я для того, щоб
потім відновлювати країну ми маємо
чітко розділити які частини людської
особистості потребують нашого постійного
контролі допомоги та турботі перше-це
все-таки тіло ми не можемо його залишити
не нашої уваги тут загалом багато
говорять медики говорять про це ті хто
має відношення до різних технік ну я
не буду це не моя специфіка
менше я хочу сказати що
потрібно спати сон один із найголовніших
компонентів зараз навіть якщо він
переривчастий тільки уві сні мозок очищається
від продуктів метаболізму та
розподіляє ту інформацію, яку ми
вбираємо щомиті і якщо ми не будемо
спати хоча б коротко на жаль це
приведе однозначно найважчим і
нервового виснаження
спати пити воду якщо не хочеться їсти не
є тому, що під час стресу живу
так просто зупиняється він не
бере участь перетравлення їжі тому що
економить енергію тобто прислухатися до
своєму організму і правильно дихати якщо
стресів зараз пити воду але про
Це дочка розповість медики наступне це
я б томськ підтримка власного
свідомості підтримка мозку на першому місці
ця інформація ось дивіться чого більше
всього боїться людський мозок це
кількість інформації це коли людина
нескінченно скролити стрічка дивляться
цікавиться на всіх джерел особливо
і народну всякий випадок і російською
щоб знати про штутгарт взагалі собі
думає і виходить когнітивний
дисонанс мозок не в змозі
переробити такий широкий масштаб
інформації тому мозок боїться
кількість інформації це перша друга
мозку боїться швидкості споживання
інформацію я кажу боїться перебільшено
він страждає він виснажується в якийсь
момент потрібний тому що ось зараз
коласу на стан тривоги і потрібно
миттєве людині переробити
безліч інформації для того, що потім
вирішити що він робитиме з цим і це
просто коли людина заганяє себе в
якийсь нескінченний динамічний
процес споживання інформації мозок бає
мозок не сприймає такої швидкості йому
потрібно розподіляти йому потрібно критично
ставитися до того що він споживає і
третє це висока мотивація тієї
інформації яку людина вбирає то
їсти йому потрібно вижити самому нам із вами
допомогти іншому та як цю інформацію
якимось чином об'єднати як
колумбійській створити якусь колаборацію
з абсолютно не поєднуємо ними фактами
ось ці три моменти виснажують наші
когнітивні функції порушуємо мислення
прибиваючи пам'ять
з'являється повна неможливість аналізу
і синтезу про найголовнішу інтеграцію в
нас інформації тому цього робити
не можна я весь час транслюючи своїм
пацієнтам та колегам у яких проводжу
супервізію давайте так вибираємо
кілька джерел і даємо мозку
перерозподілити цю інформацію
тобто ось це надзвичайно важливим
значить ще що найкраще працює
стані або в ситуації
травми вільні у якому ми з вами живемо
я називаю таке і
які обставини
марафону і це власне і я вигадала
це справді ми з вами в марафоні
тому що ось ті, хто займається
марафонським бігом часто прирівнюють ось
та витрата власного ресурсу як на
війні і є певна психологія
марафону перше це відкладене отримання
задоволення це ось для нас як ми
хочемо щоб світ настав завтра ми цього
надзвичайно цим ми все робимо для того
щоб він настав ми намагаємося створити
максимально і
обставини навколо себе ми робимо
все що може, але не все від нас залежить
тому ось це вміння здатність
пролонгувати
ось та задоволенню вірити в нього
знати але пролонгувати щоб не було
такого відчуття що якщо завтра не кінець
війні тоді кінець мені
наступне це проміжна мета і ось
як марафон добігу до того стовпа
добігу до того дерева
надзвичайно важливо ось людина
запланувало на сьогодні записав
виконав і наприкінці гнівно він обов'язково
видихни та отримає якесь задоволення
ось та задоволення яке просто
необхідно для того, щоб потім вірити
собі для того, щоб організм довіряв
власному мозку що мозок його не
доб'є, що він не змусить його в марафоні
бігти нескінченно без перерви та третє
що надзвичайно важливо відпочивати та
відновлюватися ведеться на ходу
є то прискорюючись, то сповільнюючись і ось ті
хто використовує все ось ці достатньо
нехитра але дуже добре працюючий
особливо зараз способи ось ці
механізми правильного проживання та
відновлення ці люди почуваються
набагато краще
що ще хотіла б сказати якийсь
питання чи а так я хотів було звучати
харчування до задають наші для дачі c
красуються інформації то 22, давайте
спробуємо їх прикро ти б там ні ще до
негативних новим топ тієї округу від акули
3 можеш народ іванівну бакшиш і і як і
повідомляти про своїх близьких і де що ти
хочеш там удома
скажу наступне тут працює той
спосіб який працює та мирний час
безумовно зараз негативних
негативних новин більше і ми їх з
вами читаємо все по-іншому ніяк
поряд із цим у нас є і позитивна
ніг влади ми обов'язково повинні їх
якось комплектувати щоб вони взагалі
були в унісон тобто так дійсно
є ситуації, яка викликає
тахікардію ми у нас але ми також можемо
прочитати на наших джерел на наших
інформаційних ресурсів те, що ми
проходимо через цю війну і ми маємо
багато перемог і це великі перемоги тобто
comply створювати якийсь компенсаторний
механізм
ось владимир як ви думаєте якщо вам
запропонують погану хорошу новину
ви почнете збірну
хочу порекомендувати як психотерапевт
завжди потрібно починати добрі особливо і
зараз і особливо нашим родичам
близьким літнім дітям чутливим
людям тому що чоловіки до речі завжди
починати з поганої я з цим впораюся
перейду і до добрих давайте почнемо
все-таки з гарної новини
давайте почнемо з гарною тому що
тоді у нас будуть сили побороти погану
новина тому чутливим людям і
певним категоріям населення
починаємо з того ми перемагаємо ми переможемо
але є ще деякі моменти, які ми
повинні вчити ось цьому акценту йому
вагона гарному приводу pdm у як-як
перший аспект і ось я і так
також усім про контекст розмиву скажемо
так швидко біля дошки досі я думаю що я
че ти там із друзям та колегам і
бла-бла-бла та
я за методикою люди починають за це я кіт
не знаю через сто краще через просто
звуку дати його баширова то й а червоне
радий і топ тільки вийшов гарний крокви
цього на ній вікна розбудити обидва опинимося
цін на піну наша пропаганда акули
надати радість ви майже за бідність
мови особливо вас російського боку люди
починається ширше від і каже і
відсоток від по центру б ти на ну вона ось
такі інформації може прощатися свічки
ти підірвали
це абсолютно природно я людська
акція не потрібно записувати цих людей у
токсичних справа в тому, що я завжди ось
вже 25 років я маю справу з тими, хто живе
в негативі на жаль тобто цій
депресії щось складне обмежений або
психіатричні ці стани коли
людині боляче коли йому страшно
до хороших новин він начебто
ділячись цим він по-перше намагається
почути від іншого ти не правий тобто
він все одно переслідує цю мету хоча на
перевірку виходить все-таки що він таки
підтверджується та інші
починають цей негатив множити тобто
подібне не просто притягує подібне
а подібне поширює подібне коли
у нас біль у душі ми можемо поділитися
тільки цим болем і тим не менш я
хотіла б дуже і попросити і
порекомендувати не треба поширювати
негативну інформацію особливо в
глобальних масштабах
ви ми всі цю інформацію якимсь
все ж паскаль поширюємо
ми ділимося цю інформацію давайте хоча
б міксувати до речі в один момент
людина може прийняти рішення, що він
хоча б частково починає оптимістично
ставитися до того, що відбувається я маю на увазі
не вільний війна це біль і смерть я
має ідуть те, що відбувається навколо неї що
він все-таки вирулюй що він допомагає
жити іншим, що він підтримує тварин
що природа за нього що наша справа правильна
і тоді ось цей реалістичний оптимізм
реалістичний оптимізм починає працювати
не тільки на нього це ж закони природи
закони фізики та на оточення і
поступово це підходить у звичку
тому що принцип не можу не сказати
що є люди для яких чи мирно
або поширення негативної
інформації було маст хев звичкою їх
життєвою позицією і з цим на жаль
скоріше для підлітка липня ще одна,
не таблицю і
cool і людина п р с т і якусі
мотивувати на будете нові ну там не
знаю прийшла інформація шов був і дружба
від українців та та й нулям сильну реакцію
ж - за раз читав знаю чистим звіром ви
так вже 0 абсолютні конфігурації
ціну в інтернеті інформації вже ховається
не актом жити вони акт шукаю я важливу для
кожного знака просто я випадково
інформація про звучання на видачу вечір ще
може лікувати етапі 100, а може говорити
про те ж звикнути до смерті чи можливо
є речі які мені можливо ви
і яких країн тобто все-таки навіть
коли
обговорювали з солдатами, які воювали на
вам не військовими після другої світової
війни та питали звикали лівак
смерті таки 80 відсотків людей
відповідала, що до цього звикнути не можна і
щоразу боялися і щоразу
пригинаючись і все-таки така реакція
можливо вона може бути через
того що людина все-таки це перша
причина та тобто на початку людина
вкрай емоційно реагує
поступово починає згасати
починає адаптуватися до інформації не
до смерті від інформації до першого другого
є так зване ультра
парадоксальна фаза
неврозу втома або нервового виснаження
це коли психіка починай реагувати
позамежним гальмуванням щоб не
відбувалося людина як під наркозом те
є виникає така наркотична
стан мозок захищає свого господаря
від того, щоб не зламалася людина від
щоб не сталося ось уже
абсолютного стану виснаження з
якого іноді практично немає виходу
тобто ось це остання стадія
неврастенії і тому начебто
впорскується деяка навіть не
заспокійливе, а ось як наркоз
людина починає відчувати себе майже без
чуттєвим і вже
починає також сприймати власну
долю чи обставини його життя теж
трохи як під якимось таким ось туманом
шукаємо станом це може бути у кожного
з нас працює психіка головне завдання
якій захистити свого господаря свій
організм іноді це відбувається можу
тільки сказати що не у всіх і не по
будь-якому приводу тобто таке може бути
але не у всіх і не завжди
добре давайте туди і tab 2 дтп купити
сумка ось став станції травми винаку ми
проживаємо кольори все це вантажу менше
новачок що ти перебуваєш без посеред
у зоні бойових дій на tgc
твоя душа сильна там навчаються там твої
околиця твої знаю там твоє місце твоє
роботу і так далі що ось так що так
за пунктами коротко буквально 123 можна
зуби-то рахунок мінімізувати їх вчать на
злитки то чоловікам у 77 тяжі ти я
підмітаю там нехай іншого проводиться
приклад там бабусі дідуся свої якісь
depth та дітьми що та війни та ми не
знається ціна в сажі team liquid класу c
стоїть запасів будинку мати but i аби
не було війни і так далі і так далі
тут і cc рівноправно знає і відпадний по
кулям салоники з такою а наступна
покоління і так далі в дружині таки
зараз працюючим по мінімуму
насамперед у людини є така
особливість Ілля б сказала можливість
і здатність називається вона resilient
ність це здатність нервової системи
організму людини гнуться але не ламатися
це вроджена здатність яка є
навіть у людей з певними
психіатричними відхиленнями природа
наділяє людину здатністю
переживати найважчу обставину
тому що природа не має тупикових шляхів
розвитку
що включає в себе resilient ність
насамперед це розуміння що всьому
настає кінець і поганому теж тобто
ось ця віра надія любов для багатьох
зараз віра надія це медицина
бідність це взагалі ні про що це тільки
дратує просто потрібно правильно
розуміти що це така віра в те, що це
не нескінченна що це закінчиться
перше друге це абсолютний аналіз того
що світ навколо нас нас не кинули їсти
питання у кожного з нас є питання у
нашого уряду зрозуміло ми залишаємось
реалістами проте зараз
контексті цього не тільки війни але
якогось антропологічного переходу
меггі єдина жінка у центрі але ми
перше вийдемо і станемо законодавцями
свобод і миру для всіх нас чекає нам
потрібно протриматися нам потрібно збережеться
і на нас чекає велике майбутнє нашу країну в
цьому ніхто не сумнівається
подавати аналізу, що зараз дуже важко
нам потрібно впоратися, але у нас є
майбутнє загалом до війни дуже багато
була інформація було багато матеріалів про
тому що ми живемо ментальному світі тобто
наші думки наш внесок у майбутнє формує
наше сьогодення та зараз загалом такі
думки не дуже актуальні, проте
ми живемо справжнім
ми плануємо сьогодні на сьогодні ми
плануємо що ми стали сьогодні щоб
отримати задоволення у контексті
цього але нам обов'язково потрібно
замислюватися нам потрібно вкладатися че
вкладати частину нашої лізи у майбутнє
наше найближче майбутнє та наше глобальне
майбутнє тоді ми звідти отримуємо сили
бо як казав віктор франкл
просто золоті слова якщо є для чого
тоді вже не так важливо як мета
якщо людина має зараз неможливо
без мети ми маємо спільну мету перемогти
але в нас ще кожен з нас має
індивідуальна наша унікальна мета
дуже важлива оточувати себе однодумність
однодумців надзвичайно важливо
спілкуватися з людьми які не добиває
таки допомагають піднятися навіть тим хто
тимчасово впав таким чином ми будемо
регулювати от цю так би мовити
слабкість у наших лавах це нормально
кожна людина може дати слабину
надзвичайно важливо таки я вже про це
говорила дуже
уважно поставитися до свого тіла
тому що я хоч і психотерапевт але я
завжди кажу що мудрість тіла тим вас
старше нашого мозку тіло підкаже
інтуїтивно допоможе саме ну це як
знаєте відкривається друге дихання коли
здається вже не можеш узагалі піднятися
дрон жиру здоровий дух таланти та слова
тіло потрібно ставитись надзвичайно
уважно останнє, що я хочу сказати
це дуже важливо просто щоб людина не
витрачав свої сили на те, чого ще немає
зараз багато йде у багатьох йде мова у
посттравматичному розладі та багато
вже починають боятися, що навіть після того
як активну дію не будуть
відбуватися в нашій країні що коли
почнеться загалом ось час жити жити
люди просто не зможуть через те, що
посттравматичне стресове
розлад вдарить по повній програмі
отож володимира дорогі друзі не всім
ним усіх якщо абсолютно офіційно
що по-перше вражає не всіх
що не означає, що слабка людина вийде
із цієї ситуації абсолютно зруйнованим
це абсолютно не факт це не так дуже
багато хто пройде цю ситуацію ось просто
потім згадайте мої слова без
стресового ось цього
пост-травматичного розладу тому
що ми настільки
ось якось абсолютно в єднанні ми
настільки в кооперації з комунікації ми
йдемо єдиним фронтом допомагають один одному
тому не треба боятися і не треба лікувати
те, чого ще немає і що найголовніше
перебуваючи в стані військової травми не
треба зупинятися просто йти
проживати відчувати берегти себе перед
і хоч на ходу але тим не менш ці ось у
стін ритмом з тим темпом з тією швидкістю
наскільки ми можемо але йти прислухаючись
до себе
допомагаючи іншим і стали цілі у майбутньому
чудово чи слухаю я так прямо у вас
сьогодні вийшла та й материнка cause now боку
і навіть щури sims 3 бог ще я так на
цієї каламуті але мотивів plus top то
заряджаючий вийшов для нас там у я хочу
подарунка ось уже сильно вас це ще знайшли
годину виділити я бачив і годину для того
щоб це доля ви будете нашу
платформу за те, що поділилися з нами
крутим і ричачи маяки і ну так допомагають на
правду переосмислити це що за
розмивається знав ну і хочу показати вам
успіхи у вашій практиці бути буду
вас навіть dobra дякую велике і вам
володимира вам дорогі друзі та всім нам
перемоги мирного неба дякую за
запрошення таке друзі всім мирного
увечері мирну вночі по великому з вами
завтра о 20 екзар до побачення